y llegamos ya a la capital española ahí
se encuentra nuestra corresponsal marina
colorado vamos entonces a hablar porque
regresa hoy al país el rey emérito juan
carlos primero tras dos años viviendo en
emiratos árabes unidos son marina muy
buena tarde de jueves porque se fue el
rey emérito y porque regreso ahora
pues regula antes de contestarte a esas
dos preguntas que me hace este cuento
que la visita que hace el rey emérito
juan carlos a españa es fugaz es tan
solo cinco días y es curioso porque por
así decirlo antepone el placer a la
familia porque durante todo el fin de
semana desde esta tarde que llegue a
españa va a estar en el noroeste de
españa en una regata en una competición
de barcos de vela en la costa como bien
dije del noroeste de españa no será
hasta el lunes que venga a madrid y se
reúna en el palacio de la zarzuela que
es la residencia oficial de los reyes de
españa con su hijo el rey felipe sexto
con la reina social su mujer y con
algunos otros miembros de la familia ese
mismo lunes se va a devolver a emiratos
árabes unidos- me preguntabas por qué se
fue y por qué vuelve pues se fue porque
desde el 2010 ha habido varios casos de
corrupción que empezaron salpicando a su
yerno y que han ido salpicando le a él a
partir del año 2012 en el que su nombre
se veía involucrado en casos de
comisiones irregulares
cuantiosas de blanqueo de dinero la
presión fue tal que en 2014 abdicó en su
hijo que se convirtió en el rey felipe
sexto y en 2019 hasta que hasta el 2019
estuvo en la vida pública sin embargo en
2019 dejó de estarlo y el rey le quitó
el sueldo constitucional que le
pertenecía o que le permitía la
constitución española que cuesta unos
doscientos mil euros al año y en junio
perdón en agosto de 2020 fue cuando
decidió
comentarle a su hijo la decisión de que
se iba a ir a vivir a emiratos árabes
unidos- justo unos meses después de que
la fiscalía abriera un último caso en su
contra porque vuela bueno y se fue
porque según él quería facilitarle la
tarea a su hijo porque vuelve ahora pues
porque hasta marzo de este año no ha
sido que la fiscalía española ha cerrado
todos esos casos que tenía pendientes el
rey emérito juan carlos en españa' eso
sí lo se cerró pese a constatar que y
había varios delitos cometidos lo que
pasa que habían prescrito
cuando el rey cometió estas
irregularidades fiscales
el monarca gozaba de lo que en españa se
llama la inviolabilidad del rey que es
un beneficio que le otorga la
constitución española de 1978 allá
habría que cambiarle entonces el título
de la canción porque ese fue y porque
volvió marina pero entonces con la
vuelta le pregunta a las principales
reacciones en españa sobre la visita de
juan carlos
pues la monarquía y el rey juan carlos
en particular es una figura o un ente
que suscita bastante división en la
sociedad española hay que recordar que
el rey juan carlos fue una figura muy
importante en la transición democrática
española después la dictadura de
francisco franco y sobre todo en frenar
el intento de golpe de estado que hubo
en febrero de 1981 él al ser jefe de
estado y jefe de las fuerzas armadas fue
el que pudo frenar este intento de golpe
de estado militar pero en 2021 una
asociación una plataforma de medios
independientes hicieron una encuesta en
la que le preguntaban al pueblo español
qué modelo de estado querían un 39 por
ciento voto por la república y un 9 31
por ciento por la monarquía eso sí hubo
otro tercio de la población que
respondió que estaban indecisos
una gran mayoría de la población
española si le gustaría que el rey juan
carlos
respondiera ante la justicia por estos
actos cometidos aunque hayan prescrito o
fueran no fueran posible de juzgar por
esta inviolabilidad del rey por otro
lado dentro de política el gobierno la
vertiente socialista del gobierno acepta
y atañe la la decisión de la casa real
de que vuelva el rey eso sí no permitió
que éste se fuera a dormir en el palacio
de la moncloa los brevemente los
partidos de derecha reciben con
bienvenida al rey y en la vertiente más
de izquierdas del gobierno el partido
podemos dice que el rey solo debería
volver para rendir cuentas ante la
justicia
marina muy rápidamente porque ya me
estoy comiendo mucho tiempo como está el
calor haya como sigue la hora de calor
pues menos mal hoy hay bastante brisa en
madrid y se está razonablemente bien
pero hoy es su turno se supone que hoy
es el primero de los días de esto que
nos espera por ahora los termómetros
están a cerca de cerca de unos 32 grados
o algo así pero se espera que en gran
parte de españa los termómetros rocen
los 40 grados y eso que estamos solo a
19 de mayo yo no quiero ni pensar cómo
va a ser el verano aquí ya os contaré